the cost of the war in Iraq is now
surpassed 1 trillion dollars that's more
money than our country is spent on any
war besides World War two and that
doesn't even include the Pentagon's
annual operating budget which will cost
taxpayers an additional four hundred and
eighty billion dollars this year our
government is so serious about National
Defense that they're even protecting us
from the alien menace
welcome to earth 1.6 million dollars in
the 2008 defense spending bill is
earmarked for SETI the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence since the
1960s SETI scientists have been
listening for evidence of intelligent
life elsewhere in the universe with the
goal of answering the question are we
alone I would rank it among the most
important questions ever answered
because the question is so old so are we
alone well there haven't been any
confirmed detections made by any of the
SETI instruments to date but if you just
take it from a statistical vantage point
given the numbers of stars and the
numbers of planets that are certainly
out there I have no doubt that that we
have company city is doing some pretty
fascinating work but why are they
receiving money from the Defense
Department our aliens really a threat to
our national security the alien menace
scenario is not something that I lose
any sleep over at all detecting the
signal in no way means that the
civilization that sent that has detected
us so I think we're pretty safe since
1993 said he has been funded almost
exclusively by private donations a few
years ago Microsoft co-founder paul
allen poe need up 25 million dollars to
get the Allen telescope array project
off the ground and lots of other
individuals and corporations have
followed suit also a lot of these people
have bought telescopes here you can buy
one for 150 thousand dollars and you
don't get to keep the telescope but you
do get your name on it so why is SETI
receiving money that's supposed to be
used for national defense the 1.6
million dollars that SETI received is
called an earmark earmarks are one way
that our elected officials funnel
federal tax dollars back to people in
their home districts in this case the
sponsoring representative was Anna Eshoo
the democratic representative from
SETI's district Republican Tom Coburn of
Oklahoma is an outspoken critic of
earmarks in the
Senate earmarks are the gateway drug for
overspending because earmarks are used
to get people to vote for bills they
would never otherwise vote for probably
one of the worst things that that occurs
with earmarks is it makes us pigs at a
trough to see how much we can get for
our state the seti subsidy costs each US
citizen less than a penny a year and
therein lies the problem none of us has
a very strong incentive to speak out
against any particular earmark but the
recipients have a very strong incentive
to make sure the subsidies keep coming
think what it does is is it creates an
unfair and unbalanced representative
government is if you've got money and
you can influence things in Washington
you get benefit if you don't have money
and you can influence you're not
necessarily benefited the real losers
however our children and our
grandchildren nope no family member
would spend their grandkids life savings
on a a a non essential item so they
could look good yet we do it routinely
in fact 520 of the 535 members of
Congress received earmarks in 2008
including Robert Byrd there's no
question Robert Byrd is the biggest year
marker of all time unlike Paul Allen
Robert Byrd didn't have to use his own
money to get a telescope named after him
in his home state of West Virginia in
2008 earmarks funded fruit fly research
in France a private aquarium in chicago
and the charles b Rangel center for
public service they're not big dollars
to us in washing they're very big
dollars to individuals and when you add
up all these earmarks the numbers get
really scary this year eleven thousand
six hundred and ten congressional
earmarks cost taxpayers over seventeen
billion dollars having the press highly
involved and scrutinizing not only just
a few of the year marks but the
connections between earmarks and
relationships connections between
earmarks and campaign
I think is a highly critical need that
we've not seen enough of if you think
SETI is a good idea you can make a
donation at SETI dot org if you think
earmarks are a bad idea you might want
to call your own representative and ask
some hard questions about earmarks I
think when the American people get it
they're going to throw this process out
for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie